ah so Doctor Who 50th anniversary aired
Oh anybody who watched my little video a
while back with some predictions about
this I was wrong I was wrong about
everything and not sure I've ever been
this happy to be wrong actually kind of
funny while watching it because I
started out really liking it and the
middle I started to waver by the end I
was loving it and then looking back on
it I actually liked the whole thing from
start to finish I'm gonna talk fairly
freely about some spoiler territory so
just go away if you care I loved how it
opened and when the doctors first
started meeting each other was all great
stuff it did start to lose me a bit in
the middle because it was so much so
much time was being spent on the Zygons
and I was sort of scratching my head and
going well wait a minute I thought this
was supposed to be about the war dr.
John Hurt's version and what he does in
the time war what happened with that and
by the end I came to appreciate what it
was that was going on because it wasn't
really about what that version of the
doctor did it's about how by being with
these other versions of himself he
didn't have to do it here's another
funny thing you'd think with this kind
of fairly massive bit of retconning it
would create all kinds of mess actually
for me it ties up a number of loose ends
like for instance the fact that they
were straggling Daleks the moment was
supposed to wipe out all Time Lords
except for the doctor and all Daleks and
it worked for the time wars yes the
master survived but he was not
physically a Time Lord at the time he
was physically human so we can skip that
one but the Daleks
there were stragglers there have always
been stragglers why was it so completely
effective in taking up the Time Lords
but not as effective against the Daleks
well now we have an answer because he
didn't really wipe them all out that
would account for why there were
stragglers it was something that I
always had kind of bugged me for a while
like it was establish
but there's straggling Daleks but there
will never be straggling Time Lords well
why now we know why as I was watching it
my my brain started to click and try and
figure out how this worked with the end
of time and Rassilon and all that going
on but that fits in too they dressed it
in the way that I love these continuity
issues being addressed with a single
tossed off line from the Time Lord
general who it was told that the High
Council was off elsewhere deliberate he
says the heck with the High Council so
it's all going on in parallel the High
Council of Time Lords is off preparing
the final sanction not even aware that
he's saving them Rassilon still brings
Gallifrey to earth for the end of time
part two but when the doctor banishes
Gallifrey away he's not sending it back
to the time where to be destroyed
instead he's just sending it back to
this pocket of time and bonus this gives
us a way that the master can come back
because he's just off in the pocket
universe with everybody else I don't
think I could recreate the size of the
smile that was on my face when all
versions of the doctor came to save the
planet every last one of them we even
got that tiny little glimpse of Peter
Capaldi Tom Baker Tom Baker that was
brilliant that was right up there with
using Paul McGann for the day of the
doctor mini episode that led up to this
I've really got no complaints about this
as I said at the time watching it my
brain was kind of starting to pick it
apart but looking back on it now all the
pieces fit and actually make some stuff
better that I didn't like so much before
Rose Tyler I loved the way they used
Billie Piper in this and actually it now
makes me like the bad wolf thing which
despite my t-shirt I didn't like the
whole bad wolf thing in that first
series it bugged the heck out of me but
now they brought it full circle in a way
that I'm like oh oh I mean the bad wolf
just it seems so arbitrary to me before
now it really feels like it's got depth
and it's got meaning be back for the
Christmas special oh yes